* the state 1 where each of these coefficients are complex meaning they
have both real and imaginary parts so they tell us about the probabilities but they also hide another quantity called
the phase some coefficient C can be written like
this where C equals the magnitude times this phase where this fi is the
phase it's a bit like the phase of a wave or the location of a wave's crests and troughs if two waves are in Phase
with one another so their crests and troughs line up then they'll combine to form a wave twice as
high we call this constructive interference if they're out of phase like
this then they interfere destructively completely canceling each other out to see how the phase can cause
interference in our Quantum coin let's try to apply the hadamard two times instead of just once now classically
this wouldn't make any sense if applying the hadamard is equivalent to flipping a coin then you can't flip a coin that's already flipping but let's see what
happens Quantum mechanically so we apply the hadamard twice and we sample the resulting State
amazingly we no longer have a 50/50 probability the resulting histogram shows that for every case we measure the
Cubit to be in the zero state so the second hadamard has returned the Cubit to the zero state where we started it's
a bit tricky to see at first but this is thanks to the interference of the quantum state but rather than
interfering in real space like an actual wave the interference is happening in abstract information space of the Cubit
the second hadamar gate caused the Zero part of the superposition to interfere constructively while the one part of the
superposition interfere destructively and disappeared let's explore further we can change the phase using
something called a phase gate so now let's PL apply a hadamard to create the superp position apply a phase shift of
Pi radians and then apply the second hadamard now it seems like our Quantum coin always comes out to be in the one
state the pi phase shift exchanged the parts of the superposition state that were in phase and out of phase with one another
so the final state is one instead of zero this would be like flipping a coin and while it's midair being able to
somehow apply an operation that would guarantee that it always landed heads up or always heads down depending on the
operation impossible in the classical case but not in the quantum case what we've learned from these experiments is
that this new capability of the quantum coin is due to its phase a quality that a Quantum superp position has but a
classical probability distribution doesn't so the usual coin flip actually isn't that great of an analogy to a
superposition because it doesn't say anything about this phase I think we can do better I'm going to do another
experiment with our coin I have the coin sitting on the table heads up to make it heads down I can just flip it over this
is the computational equivalent of a not gate say we want to construct an operation that if applied twice would be
equivalent to this knot gate we can call this operation a square root of knot so think about what we're physically doing
when we apply the knot gate we're rotating it 180° around for example the x-axis so if we were to rotate the coin
just 90° around the x-axis that would give us the square root of knot so we've applied
our square root of knot and the coin is just sitting on its Edge now we can ask is it heads up or heads down well
clearly it's neither but we could add a step to the measurement process to force it to be heads up or heads down now the
coin will fall to either heads up or heads down side with equal probability again in principle we could predict
which way it'll fall but in practice this is difficult enough to predict to make it essentially random if I want to
measure whether it's heads left or right I can squash it in that direction and a similar way and it will again give us a
50/50 probability of left and right but in this Dimension heads front or back
the head is already facing forward so 100% of the time we will measure it heads forward so while the x and z
measurements yielded R random results the Y measurement will always yield the same result if we think back to the
quantum coin flip experiment from the previous section this is reminiscent of how the quantum coin behaved after
applying the hadamard the Cubit was measured to be either zero or 1 with 50/50 probability in the Z Direction but
always the plus State and never the minus State along X this suggests that perhaps a coin standing still on its
Edge is a better way to visualize a superposition state of a cubit than a coin wildly flipping through the air
let's apply a square root of knot gate on our Quantum coin in kcit we have this simple
circuit then we'll use estimator to check the expectation value of the three observables X Y and Z which are kind of
like collapsing our coin along each of the three dimensions like I just showed so the expectation values are 0
minus one and 0 for X Y and Z respectively this is the same result we
got for the square root of not rotation applied to the classical coin in fact there's a precise analogy between the
coin and the Cubit State now we can visualize the Cubit State as a vector pointing in the direction of the heads
on the coin normal to the Sur surface of the coin so heads up or the zero State
on the quantum coin is equivalent to a vector pointing straight up heads down or one is pointing straight down and any
equal superposition of 0 and one points horizontally the phase of the quantum State determines the exact horizontal
Direction at points for example whether it's pointing along the xais or along the Y AIS or somewhere in
between this Vector is known as the block vector and it fully and uniquely determines the quantum state of a single
Cubit we can now reimagine every gate that we've seen in this video as a rotation or a series of rotations on the
coin or equivalently on the Block Vector the knot gate is a rotation of
180° around the xais when applied to our zero state or heads up it flips to the
down state or one square root of knot is just 90° around that same xais starting
from the heads up State this rotates it to heads front a phase gate is a rotation of five around the Z axis since
heads up is aligned with the Z axis this doesn't do anything to the coin the hadamar gate is a bit trickier we
initially likened it to flipping a coin making the coin spin uncontrollably in the air but the hadamard is actually a